hello and welcome to footnotes my name
is matt simon i am here to recap the
most ravishing language and ideas and
last week of Wired first up this week we
have sleeper sharks which are considered
to be the lazy oaths of the depths wired
science this week took a look at a study
that was trying to figure out how
exactly these sharks for catching seals
when they can swim no more than two
miles an hour and most of them are blind
because i have parasitic worms attached
to their eyeballs turns out that polar
bears have been eating the seals while
they're sleeping on land so when they're
sleeping in the ocean all the Sharks
have to do is sniff them out mosey up
and take a big ol bite out of them now
this is highly embarrassing for the
seals you can imagine one waking up in
the morning missing a flipper and his
friends come up to him and say dude what
happened you got your flipper taken by a
sleeper shark and the CEO would respond
with something like well first of all I
thought he'd be sleeping at that hour
and second of all I really wish you'd
lay off me on this one because I woke up
this morning one flipper short it's
dentally ISIL owners will eat these
sharks which can actually be very
poisonous if you don't treat it properly
but because they're chock-full of what
is essentially anti-freeze on account of
the very deep cold depths that I live in
and in order prep it you have two broad
it for months on end and when that
happens it acquires this very ammonia
odor it should be said that it actually
tastes a little bit better than it
smells however Anthony Bourdain have
said that it is the worst food he's ever
tasted and that chef who yells a lot
Gordon Ramsay was filmed eating it very
briefly stop yelling in order to throw
up and then resume yelling how Bjork
feels about this food I can't rightly
say next up dog food naturally at
Google's big IO conference last week the
company announced a music streaming
device called the Nexus Q and in an
exclusive report from our own John
Phillips he
mentioned that Google employees have
been dogfooding the device at office
parties now dogfooding is a fairly
obscure term outside of the tech
community it basically means for a
company to give products to its
employees to test out with the idea that
if it's good enough for the employees
it's good enough for the general
populace Sergey Brin has been doing this
rather publicly with the Google glass
project those are the augmented reality
specs that our features have been
promising us for decades you might be
wondering how I now like this came to be
a verb and the story goes and I really
hope this is true that there was a
president of a pet food company who
would go to the shareholder meetings and
just dig in to a can of his own dog food
this is great for inspiring confidence
in your product not so great for
inspiring confidence in yourself as a
business leader
you